here the LEC which stands for the Large
Hadron colliders it's a and you know
particle accelerator it's going to
collide hadrons which is so for example
a proton is an example of a hadron it's
a particle has made up of quarks which
thought to be the fundamental
constituents of matter and what it's
going to actually it's going to be
asking some very important question
first of all is going to be able to take
matter to the so its fullest extreme
okay it's the extreme sports of matter
it's going to take matter today to
energy scales that will basically
simulate moments right after the Big
Bang right so it's going to be able to
recreate in the sense the physics that
we have with you know I'll naturally
don't have access to and in doing so
we'll be able to see things we've never
seen before now you know few Attica
physicists we're very inventive you know
we caught up with like good theories and
one of the big theories that we have we
have something called a standard model
which is this model that really explains
all of physics going down to you know 15
decimal points right after zero
centimeters okay let's go all the way up
to ours our distance scale all of the
biochemistry not to you know is really
born on to the same type of physics this
standard model is a theory that unifies
these the forces except gravity to
explain all this physics and it's worked
so far pretty well and there is one
interesting thing about the stand of all
of that is an input a theoretical input
that we've yet to test which goes back
to the question about ease equal to MC
square that M which stands for the mass
the way that empties in actually
directly enters into this standard model
but the way a mint is in is through a
particle called a Higgs particle named
after physicists scottish physicist
named his name is peter higgs and this
Higgs particle
is a thing that one of the things we are
looking for at the lmc well that would
be some people to say so you know the
standard model predicts this head needs
this Higgs particle we have yet to find
it the LHC will be trying to find this
Higgs particle now if it finds a Higgs
particle then it's some people say the
game is over because you know we have
this completion of the Santa model you
know this was the one Holy Grail that
we're looking for by the way the Higgs
particle is a very important theoretical
ingredient because it explains it's a
particle that is a carrier of mass okay
so it endow smash everything else
without the Higgs particle to interact
with everything all the substance that
were made up of for example would have
no mass it would travel at the speed of
light it wouldn't have the Masters
slowing down the Higgs is like the glue
that slows everything else down okay and
the problem is that the standard model
is a great job and it has this Higgs
particle that it predicts but this is
weird thing that we call fine-tuning
which is you have to imagine the Higgs
has a dial on it that the more you know
you've turned down up this pricks
particle gets heavier or lighter alright
and there's inset and also quantum
mechanics influences this dial it can
make the dial go this way that way
alright sometimes we don't have control
over that dial and the question is why
is the Higgs the dial on this for the
heck that dials the mass of the Higgs
tuned to be exactly what is necessary
for us to have our mass so that's called
a fine tuning problem so even if we find
his Higgs we would still have to explain
that and it appears that we are right
now in a theoretical conundrum in in in
physics right now which is we don't
really have a good grips on this fine
tuning so and there are no good answers
to that supper edition so now bringing
that back to if we find the Higgs that
means
we'll have to deal with this fine tuning
problem which pretty much everyone wants
to avoid ok but if but at the same time
the basic structure of the standard
model will be over with and there will
be no more games no more theoretical you
know building to do for half of the
sound of model if we don't find the
Higgs then that's good for me because
that means we have work to do and it
means that the standard model was a big
part of it was just wrong and we and
also for me it means that the way we
think about mass when it comes to
particle physics needs to be we need
saweet we need completely new ideas and
that the Higgs idea if this Higgs
particle was just the wrong way if we
don't find it there's a worldwide
collaboration that involves thousands
thousands of people all around the world
and in Geneva Switzerland so it's a lot
of people are involved in this
experiment well the energy scales are
you know we're talking about you know
I'm the order of a thousand Giga
electron volts remember about 10
electron volts is what it takes a you
know if you if you liberate an electron
right from an atom from hydrogen um so
now a Giga electron volt right is on the
order of a billion electron volt so
we're talking about a thousand billion
electron volts that's the energy that
will be taken matter too so we're going
to access this amount of matter I mean
the amount of energy and we have to be
able to contain that amount of energy
because it influences magnetic fields
and all sorts of things right if you're
coned bill will be really really high if
you're trying to you know use that
amount of energy so the some theorists
have tried to say well we can create
black holes for example because the
energy scales you can actually you know
when you
fine mint orders for example you can
create if you give me enough energy I
can convert that from empty space into
matter or matter could annihilate into
emmajin so some people think well I
therefore I should be able to create a
quantum black holes i can create black
holes in this lab and then of course you
can then argue well if i create a black
hole right here on earth won't i suck
everything into the black hole right so
and then if you go on as a furious is
that going to be catastrophic i mean i
don't know i can't predict that so
that's kind of where things go but
there's a near 20 percent transit
anything what bad would happen but on
the flip side we've never actually seen
or experienced nature at that energy
scale so we just don't know what happens